hello I'm in the style Creek guy
remember it so you don't have to where
do I even begin with this Whoopi
Goldberg and a dinosaur go solving
crimes nope can't even begin with that
that's the premise the premise is so
stupid I can't even begin with it so
let's begin with how they came up with
the premise some jackass executives are
in an office saying hey we got me some
money real quick while putting
absolutely no effort into it hmm why
don't we take an a- list actor and
whatever the hell is popular right now
and team a boat together
hmm now let's see yeah oh I know how
about Betty White and a ninja turtle oh
how about William Shatner and Pokemon
that's too obvious oh I got it
how about dinner Wayans in that Gekko
from the Geico commercials mmm wait for
sar oh I got it I really got it how
about Whoopi Goldberg and one of the
dinosaurs from that TGIF sitcom fuck you
I'm lazy
fyodor eyes man and I mean man is this
weird I just don't get who thought this
had potential who would throw money at
this thinking they would honestly get it
back if I matter how did they manage to
even get some of these people I mean
they're not gigantic names but it
seriously surprised that every actor
didn't change their name to Alan Smithee
after watching this shit fest it's that
bad so as if you honestly need to ask
why this movie didn't work let's take a
look at Theodore Rex so we start off
with our intro that pretty much looks
like a bad PowerPoint presentation
billionaire Eleazar King will launch his
new Newton missile to bring on another
ice cream after mankind is extinct Cain
will reanimate the pairs of all
animals he keeps frozen in his ark oh
good at least they're taking this
seriously so we see this assassin guy
going after well da dinosaur as he tries
to kill him by letting loose a butterfly
hi wow I've never been so simultaneously
annoyed and confused at the same time
rapid duck is 2 4 in the water
hmm so after that bad dream we see Teddy
he's a dinosaur cop who lives in an
apartment with his dog zippy wait wait I
need a moment for that to sink in
oh ok as he tried to round the city that
I think was designed by Ringling
Brothers we then come across another cop
named Katy Coltrane as her and another
cop go roaming the streets for
chipmunk Jawas
the great police how are you collecting
for the policeman's ball
isn't it heroes from Harold and Maude
can we cook it earlier no way I'm hoping
for multiple suicides run Willy droop
with a lolly I'll kill ya I need an ID
on a murder victim
so after retrieving one murder victim we
get another as Rex is seen hovering over
the body of the dinosaur that he saw in
his dream like somebody had a
sensitivity attack with the keep this
incident of the Raps would you know how
to blame him because if got out could be
trouble I know here's a fun fact this
actress had to do this scene 20 times in
order to keep a straight face keen blame
her
what are you doing out in the jungle
tonight huh funny thing I was home
asleep right and all of a sudden I had
this flash deep down I knew something
was wrong wait are you telling me that
all you dinos are on the same wavelength
well it's kind of like we feel for each
other wait so not only two dinosaurs
exist in this world but they also have
psychic powers well I don't know about
you but this movie about Tyrannosaurus
Rex who solves crimes in a futuristic
city has totally lost me on his
credibility so Gover meets up with her
only friend
a little boy named Sebastian can you
swing by the playground tomorrow it's a
surprise I'm not real good with
surprises Hey
and I try really hard by I look forward
to your neva tubble kidnapping so Brooks
goes to a fundraiser for eleazar king
whose genetic discoveries are the reason
dinosaurs are walking the earth again
but for some reason our 1/10 their size
I'm uh looking for uh Commissioner Lynch
up various that nice talking to you mr.
Sommers music okay guys word of advice
don't greenlight a movie when you're
animatronics are worse than
chuck-e-cheese oh yeah he max things
over with his tail it's funny because oh
wait no it's not excuse me Teddy shaft
not many people get to meet their maker
at a fundraiser okay
Oh scuse me sir is uh something wrong
yes yes there's there's been a dinosaur
Oh on the fact that you're just you're
talking funny dinosaur I'd like to be
assigned to the case no no Teddy we all
have our pairs to follow what is it my
path leads to so what we have fringy
meat meat meat meat you no more covering
carnivore sweets yes
cookies ramaa customer and his quest for
finding that mysterious short temper
begins good new sixties oh yeah
cookies swingin tails and cookies those
are our two running jokes people these
are the nice libraries that you're gonna
have to see over and over again it's not
just thrilling aren't you excited to see
where the cookie story art goes you have
the case uh undercover we're teaming you
up well your own good
hey great the veteran pro colton hey we
already know that's not Coltrane so this
joke doesn't work out of the way guy who
was only here for a throwaway gag
Coltrane there's been a homicide and
your name came up so judge Renmark here
is teamed up with Teddy much to her
dismay teddy Rex meet Katie Coltrane hi
you two solved this case together ha
whoa whoa what what that is in public
relations
but I'm field promoting him temporarily
he's a dinosaur
she wha hey Coltrane straighten up and
fly right it's your chance for a
comeback don't blow it
please if I wanna see will be go over to
interact with dinosaurs I'd watch the
view no suspects no clues no motives so
we need to determine a cause of death
sweet Christmas when chops sing-along
has better light movements than ham
so they go to where the dead dinosaurs
body has been taken which is a museum
that seems ironically cruel as legs
decides to examine the body
doctor may I help yourself there we go
send this to captain
Alaric at headquarters then I suppose
those weird sounds he makes are never
going to be explained yeah dinosaurs
just hack up hairballs whenever they
look over a dead body yeah why not
there's a dinosaur walking around
something Christ Whoopi Goldberg
anything's possible so they find out the
dinosaur used to live in a nightclub
where other dinosaurs hang out good for
you
hey teddy
Tina how are you I'm fine okay now
you're making the 3d jaws look realistic
can you put a little bit more effort
into these puppets guys what is this ah
this ring this is hydroponic steel you
know when he talks I don't hear what
he's saying I just hear all the gears
and wheels that are moving that giant
fake head so they come across a singer
named Molly rent
well apparently knew the murder oh come
on like this joint so we can carry young
this is like a really bad hi in fact
this whole scene looks like the
tricked-out barn from fear loathing in
las vegas doesn't it I was right in the
middle of a fucking reptile zoo somebody
was giving booze that he's got dancing
won't be long now before they tear us to
shreds
so they going to question this anger
only to find out that the murder victim
used to work for Eleazar Kane I really
gotta go
I'll call ya see ya
that's not even worth addressing there's
far too many weirder things to talk
about this movie like this seem for
example Turkish readers have for an
early Halloween oh wait I've seen this
don't the Power Rangers come out and
usually people crap out of these guys
well hey well but I finally got his ID
by breaking the Coon the code the
genetic code the map of our destiny and
we're all slaves to our DNA hey wait huh
Adam okay okay let's play a game
what does this scene have to do with
this see
I mean she's not discovering anything
about Teddy being attacked so what's the
connection
you don't need your editor to play six
degrees of Kevin Bacon with your
audience guys just be straightforward
okay so the bad guys catch up with Teddy
and horrifyingly throw custard pies it
really that's that's not that bad I mean
granted it's annoying but you can't
really make that look very frank
well okay unless you added this I'm
gonna go on tour with that guy so they
returned to that assassin guy who is not
happy with their progress this is your
last chance you'll keep your eye on the
Rex and the gun or I'll stick you in a
blender blender it's funny because it
begins with a beer ha ha ha ha
so they returned to headquarters which
is looking an awful lot like a
McDonald's playground as the
Commissioner is displeased where the
hell were you when a car was stripped it
was a medivac matter back was a matter
of fact y'all autos with a stick with
Teddy you embarrass the department she
and bears
she's been here all Sinclaire over there
so while goober tries to talk with a
commissioner what the hell why are they
playing shuffleboard with Hershey's
Kisses fuckin I don't care
Teddy tries to go and find some clothing
they'll make him look more like a real
cop okay he'll impress me up good now
look nice okay
push the button okay seriously I mean
seriously people really can't dress
themselves in the future they have to
spend thousands of dollars to have
groundbreaking technology because they
don't know how to put on their fucking
socks what sense does that make
and for that matter why all these stupid
costumes is there seriously a scenario
where you're gonna need a dinosaur to
dress as a hula dancer I'm sorry but I
honestly do not see a situation where
that will be more quiet I think this
will do fine yeah you look good you look
like a real cop oh yeah because he look
so different from before now doesn't it
he'll just blend into the crowd
meanwhile at the sprinkle testicle
building the assassin finds a hostage
they can use a Keith Goldberg and Teddy
get too close
why so serious
fastest so they kidnap Sebastian by
luring him with his favorite video game
bland non-advertising blank screen
remember that game growing up I'm sure
it would get your attention if you saw
it right
so Teddy meets up with Molly again if
they head back to his place for some
Tyrannosaurus sex oh my good cookies oh
good okay good cookie cookie cookie
cookie yep the running joke of cookies
has literally just represented to the
shouting of the word now which is a
shame I saw a real potential for that
joke oh but thank God we still got the
swinging tail gag you think by the 97th
time to be annoying but it's not it's
yes it's really funny
oh you got it bad don't you oh I see you
dancing on the street under the Stars
flinging your tail around like you're
free guy you act you act like only
humans fall in love I can't understand
you why do you keep your feelings all
bottled up inside huh huh it's a
tournament drunk is that why the angles
keep tilting I'll tell you what if it is
I would've loved it it'd be the way I
could get through filling this movie too
i reconstructed a little gizmo myself
Nass tell where would our killer get a
weapon like this and techno kill circles
he's known as the toy maker somewhere on
the ninja grid wait wait wait wait a
minute wait
there was a ninja grid in this movie the
whole time we were hanging out with
these two morons a week I've been
watching a ninja print this whole time
what else have we been missing out on is
there a rock bands on skateboard grid as
well come on guys focus on the good
stuff so they go to meet this toy maker
when who welcome to dead storage we're
gonna die yeah why not I mean nothing
surprises me anymore if we want to spend
several minutes talking to an inanimate
finger puppet I'm totally okay with that
oh oh and what's this
Jerry hotdog oh of course it is if you
want a hairy hotdog to talk to a finger
puppet turn into a butterfly and float
by a bunch of helium containers I'm okay
with that now there's really no point in
questioning it since I'm trying to save
a sinking ship with a band-aid anything
I tried to do will be completely
pointless
hey welcome have some tea
are you the toy maker I've been called
many things one of them being toilet so
the toy maker escapes blows up the
building and forgets to exit the
building you know it's not much of an
escape plan if you don't actually escape
so they interrogate the guy as he
reveals Ella's ARS plan to destroy
mankind to perfect a master race
so they bust the Munchkin commune as
they get the bad guys to build them up
look at me Katie I'm a pterodactyl why
what is the purpose of this thing a Lego
plane is playing puppy with a
Tyrannosaurus Rex why does this need to
be seen well I can't say I expecting
this they made me train in here he is
the one shoot him shoot him I decided
then that I enjoy big dead what was your
name again
culture get rid of them get rid of them
well wait why don't you just shoot her
too I mean this gives her ample time to
escape yeah like that
yes because nothing blends into the
cover of darkness then bright red
shining light and a glowing Nintendo
controller why don't you just paint in
the unpooled eye on your back while
you're at it so as Teddy wakes up
Eleazar launches his doomsday missile it
reveals his evil ways here's my Ark
it contains the seats of the New Eden I
brought here breathing pairs off all
their hand while it takes minutes say
again what if it's bad okay dude
seriously you gotta run your evil plan
for battle finish I have like no idea
what you're saying right now
no okay bottom line he built a spaceship
that's an art that will keep two of
every animals safe and Teddy is going to
be one of those animals hey hold your
horses
needles creep me out you know oh one
little prick and you'll wake up in
paradise
wasn't it Tom Cruise's marriage proposal
why didn't you guys kill Oliver and Adam
huh they threatened to expose mr. Cain's
master plan oh don't you leave oh gee
she's standing by the door I can't
possibly imagine what's going to happen
or how Teddy's gonna get out of this at
all and here I thought it was going to
be cookie for me
so Goldberg saves the kid but a sharp
idea assassin who I guess messes up for
robotic armor or something
I'm just thought back to my blender Joe
B so again after not killing anybody
tinnie goes after the bad guys and tries
to stop the missile as well
ah
Jesus were they driving a Pinto
detonation minus 15 so Teddy only has
seconds to stop the missile maybe he has
to fight his way through an army of
soldiers maybe he has to find the code
to turn the missile off or maybe he just
does that what seriously that was it
no big battle or climax for oh hell why
am i complaining it makes the movie
short is my honor to promote you to
detective first class wow so the two of
them get a medal for their hard work and
that's really about it it just ends with
the word SIA like you just got done
talking to a really annoying friend that
you know in fact you will never see
again
trust me there is nothing in this movie
that you ever want to see again I don't
even know what to say about I literally
can't even comprehend the premise it's
that bad it's sort of beyond belief it's
like what Jack Nicholson would see in
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest after he
got lobotomized I see will be Goldberg
and a t-rex solving crime yes you need
to die now so if you're looking for a
spectacular disaster of a movie I
recommend teen Theodore Rex once once
I'm understaffed your crank I remember
it so you don't have to
get this cookie cookie cookie cookie